imagine using a debit card to pay for
her groceries only to have met with the
statement rejected as you scramble for
your credit card you swear you have
enough money to pay for groceries
thoughts of race around your head as you
get hit with my rejection at this point
you are certain your bank card is
getting hacked as he has top-notch
credit score you're a well blurrier
credit limit as the line behind you
starts to get worried you end up paying
with cash and hastily walk away but as
you are leaving you notice that people
at several other terminals are also
being rejected and there is one
similarity between all of them they are
all issued by JPMorgan Chase & Co as
this is what if Chase Bank ran out of
money JPMorgan Chase & Co is the biggest
bank in the u.s. and one of the biggest
financial institutions in the world
holding over 2.7 4 trillion dollars
worth of assets Chase Bank is no doubt
one of the safest places to keep her
money but one of this banking behemoths
somehow ran out of it would your life
savings be pried from right underneath
you would your house before closed but
more importantly would the US economy
collapse and enter another Great
Depression well to answer this we
actually have to take a look back at
history for a second as banks running
out of money was actually quite common
throughout the 1800's and early 1900s it
would usually start with a small local
bank filing for bankruptcy which would
lead to widespread panic that banks are
an unsafe place to keep her money
this would quickly result in people
across the country with trying all of
their cash and otherwise safe financial
institutions failing such was the case
in 1893 as depositor confidence was
dwindling as concern for the state of
the economy deepened people rushed to
withdraw their money from banks after
everything was said and done five
hundred banks were closed and 15,000
businesses would fail the unemployment
rate would peak at 43% of Michigan and
thousands of people would lose all the
money and face starvation as they were
unable to find a job
fun fact during the panic of 1893 it was
actually JP Morgan who would end up
rescuing the US Treasury moving on a
similar set of circumstances and results
would unfold during panic of 1907 but at
this point bankers had had enough this
was clearly not sustained
or good for not just the US population
but the US economy itself what the US
was lacking that pretty much every other
industrialization had was a central bank
Aleksandr Hamilton the men are a ten
dollar build you knew that this day
would one day come and that's why he was
very insistent that the US needs a
central banking system but people were
very resistant to this idea as they
believed that this wasn't a true free
enterprise system and moreover this was
associated with evil European
governments which is what they had just
fought to get away from while this
perspective is understandable logically
it was just under beta be better to have
a federal bank and after years of
stubbornness Alexander Hamilton would
get his way the First National Bank of
the United States would be established
on February 25th 1791 as you probably
already guessed though this was met with
intense scrutiny and opposition leading
the charge were founding fathers James
Madison Thomas Jefferson who were
insisting that the bank was
unconstitutional and that it benefited
merchants and investors at the expense
of the majority of the population see at
this point the population was split
between two parties not two Democrats
and the Republicans but actually the
Democrat Republicans and the Federalists
Democratic Republicans didn't want the
central bank and Federalists did
political as well as personal tensions
would grow so strong that eventually
vice president Aaron Burr would shoot
and kill Alexander Hamilton in a duel in
1804 and when it came time to recharge
the bank in 1811 without oxen Hamilton
the main supporter of the bank that Bank
would close and wouldn't you know it
financial troubles that arise almost
instantaneously and Congress would
actually charter the second bank of the
United States in 1816 only to be closed
again 20 years later in 1836 when
President Andrew Jackson would declare
it to be unconstitutional and vetoes
recharter by this point the Federalist
Party had dissolved and no one was
pushing first into a banking system and
this is what would leave the u.s. in
what is now called the free banking era
after this financial turmoil and banking
panics became rampant throughout the
1800s but things would change after the
panic of 1907 in October of 1907 JP
Morgan called for a meeting of the most
influential bankers of the time
office by putting together capital of
the biggest banks in America JPMorgan
was able to save the otherwise healthy
banks which have become victims of
bankruptcy due to widespread fear and
with all of the joint efforts the panic
was somewhat contained everyone agreed
that a central banking system was
required but arguments and debates
lasted for years and how such a system
would work as there was a wide range of
concerns from the bank hammock too much
power to ensuring that palooka
influences were blocked out after over
five years of gruesome debate the
Federal Reserve will be created on
December 23rd 1913 when President
Woodrow Wilson signed the Federal
Reserve Act into law but what exactly
does a Federal Reserve even do well the
Federal Reserve has two main goals which
are to maintain stable prices and ensure
maximum employment and production output
and they have three tools to make this
happen which are the reserve requirement
that discount rate and open market
operations the reserve requirement is
quite simple it is just a ratio of money
that financial institutions are required
to keep in liquid form this ensures that
banks never overextend and lend out too
much money discount rates are a bit more
complicated this is the interest rate
charged on banks for short-term loans
such loans is heard by the 12 regional
branches of the Fed are usually granted
for ultra short periods of time usually
24 hours or less this is simply to
shoulder any funding shortfalls and
prevent any short-term liquidity
problems and finally there is federal
open market operations arguably the most
important part of the Federal Reserve
the activities that the Federal Reserve
in the open market are determined by the
Federal Open Market Committee this is
composed of 12 men and women who meet
eight times throughout the year the SEC
key interest rates and determine whether
to increase or decrease the money supply
all of this is accomplished using
government securities which are
basically just I owe you stamens from
the US government these are perceived as
no risk investments as they're of course
backed by the US government when the Fed
sells government securities in the open
market financial institutions will loan
the government money on which the
government will pay back interest on the
other hand if the Fed buys back
born in other words loans money - or
pays back financial institutions they
pump money into the economy increasing
the overall money supply all of this is
supposed to keep the economy in check
and prevent another panic
for instance when there is an economic
recession the federal lower interest
rates giving out more money to banks and
this will hopefully stimulate economic
activity and see banks from bankruptcy
when the economy is booming the federal
increased interest rates to combat
inflation and hopefully reduced loans
that banks give out which would usually
be considered as risky loans and this
huge complicated and convoluted process
should prevent major banks from failing
but history has shown us with the Great
Depression in the 2008 economic
recession it does not always work out
like expected I know that was a lot to
take in but I think it is essential in
understanding the repercussions of Chase
Bank collapsing so going back to what if
Chase Bank ran out of money let's first
take a closer look at the potential
causes of such a devastating result
there are four major ways that this
could unfold which are a bank run
positive feedback loops regulatory
failure or contagion as for a bank run
this is a quite unlikely in today's
economy as consumer confidence is very
high on top of this Chase Bank is an
fdic-insured Bank meaning that it is
insured by the Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation so even if Chase Bank were
to collapse all depositors would receive
compensation for the Federal Reserve up
to $250,000 considering that only 20% of
Americans have over 134 thousand dollars
in savings
most Americans wouldn't be worried and
as a result a bank one is quite unlikely
next up positive feedback loops now this
is definitely something to worry about
this is when bankers get overconfident
with their lending habits they start
with risky loans just here and there but
they end up paying back this slowly
leads them lending out more and more
risky loans and all of a sudden a large
proportion of debtors can't pay back
this is precisely what happened in the
mortgage crisis of the early 2000s banks
became extremely lenient on handing out
loans which led to billions of dollars
in total losses the third cost could be
regulatory filler in which a bank crisis
rises from a lack of government
oversight for example chase might not be
mean and reserve requirements and the
government doesn't pursue any action
against them but with the economic
crisis occurring just 11 years ago the
US government's currently very stern on
enforcing banking requirements so this
too is unlikely at least as of right now
and finally contagion today in Egypt
international interdependence that
failure of one economy can create
something of a domino effect for example
when the US economy collapsed in 2008
the effects we felt across the world but
today the US economy is doing better
than ever before and that fall of
another global superpower like China is
also quite unlikely right now so this
would probably not be the reason that
Chase Bank defaults considering all of
this the most likely reason for such a
scenario would be positive feedback
loops along with slow loosening of
government regulation over several years
so what would an travel in such a
timeline well there's the realistic
outcome and the dystopian outcome and
when you get slipped on this video you
guys are probably looking for the
dystopian outcome so I'll make sure to
cover that as well but first here's the
more realistic outcome JPMorgan Chase
has actually already been at the brink
of bankruptcy during the economic
recession and the Federal Reserve had to
bail them out for 12 billion dollars but
since then they have been extremely
careful with their lending as of June
2018 JPMorgan Chase had 36 percent of
its deposits in their reserves and this
number has been steadily increasing
since the recession to put this in
perspective the Federal Reserve only
managed that 10 percent of deposits be
kept in reserves so Chase Bank has two
and a half times more than the minimum
and they would have to go quite a long
way to be put in trouble once again but
if they somehow manage to get all the
way back up there well it would be quite
anti-climactic actually we would see the
Federal Reserve lend money to Chase Bank
at really low interest rates in order to
continue operation considering that
JPMorgan Chase is the biggest bank in
the US the Federal Reserve would be
willing to go pretty far to keep the
institution alive so most likely Chase
Bank would be saved and you really
even see a difference you may come
across it on the newspaper and interest
rates may rise little but overall
everything would be about the same
especially if the other banks are still
in line but finally here it is the
reason many of you guys clicked on this
video what if Chase Bank ran out of
money and they were too far gone for the
Federal Reserve to save them well after
the bank failure is publicly announced
there's no reason to try to withdraw
your money as the FDIC would have
already taken over and consequently you
won't have access to your money and have
no control over how much money you will
lose but the FDIC is very quick and you
will receive your $250,000 worth of
insured deposits the following day if
not very soon after as for uninsured
deposits this will take several months
the FDIC would have to sell all of the
institution's assets and see how much
money if any is left for creditors but
as I said before only 20% of Americans
have more than 134 thousand dollars in
total savings so around 80% of Chase
Bank depositors will not lose any money
at all and as for the people with a
couple of million dollars in deposits
well they definitely have tens of
million dollars in other investments
people who are able to gather so much
fault
didn't accomplish it by simply working a
job but by using their savings in
growing it through investment
opportunities as well just take a look
at someone like Jeff Bezos his net worth
as of july 2019 is 164 point nine
billion dollars of which 156 billion
dollars is Amazon stock plus he has also
invested several billion dollars into
other companies like Blue Origin thus
while he may have hundreds of millions
of dollars in a Chase savings account
losing most of this money won't have
much an effect if any considering his
vast fortune in fact he would lose more
money if Amazon stock dropped by a
single dollar and this same principle
would apply to most depositors of Chase
Bank with several million dollars while
still a large loss they will be able to
sustain it without much tangible damage
the main people that will be affected by
the closing of Chase Bank will be upper
middle America The Millionaire Next Door
who doesn't have a bunch of savvy
investments or
has a high-level executive or medical
job the simple engineer who works hard
for money and has accumulated a
significant amount mainly by being cheap
and saving most of the income for
several decades unfortunately these
people will be hit the hardest and will
have no way out as for the economy as a
whole with JP Morgan controlling 2.7 4
trillion dollars worth of assets that
collapse the bank will no doubt affect
the US GDP mainly because of the
decrease investment and consumer
spending government spending will as a
result significantly increase to combat
a decrease in GDP and the US will take
on more loans increasing the national
debt hopefully the other financial
institutions aren't in a bad position as
well and considering that this is a
video about the failure of Chase Bank
alone not a full economic collapse we'll
assume that the other plans are doing
just fine but as for the US while there
would be a significant economic decline
fortunately there will most likely not
be an economic recession
unless of course other banker also
involves something else to consider is
that Chase Bank doesn't just operate in
the u.s. it actually operates in water
in different countries FDIC actually
also covers foreign investments that are
made on US soil but foreign investments
usually come from huge corporations
where again have many other assets that
any losses here would be digestible and
finally all of you guys who wrote Chase
Bank don't think that you can get away
with their free house as you will have
to pay back but you may have a couple of
months without any payments eventually
Chase assets will be sold to other
financial institutions like Citigroup or
Wells Fargo and debtors will have to
continue paying their loans to these
banks instead but don't worry
loan terms cannot be changed so your
payment won't just suddenly increase so
there is a dystopian future that a lot
of you guys were expecting but in all
reality this is very unlikely JPMorgan
Chase or technically a banks that make
up JPMorgan Chase have been around for
over a century and have seen several of
their partners come and go from
Washington Mutual IndyMac more recently
to all the big pillars in the 1800's
with JPMorgan tracing its roots altered
back to 1799
Manhattan Bank established by Aaron Burr
JPMorgan Chase & Co have been through a
lot and will most likely not end up in a
sticky situation and even if they
somehow did the Federal Reserve will
come to the rescue but that's just what
I think what do you guys think
make sure comment that down below also
if you guys liked this video they mix it
up alike and consider subscribing if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one
you